300 kilometers north of Buenos Aires on
the Western Bank of the piranha River
you'll find Rosario the farming City
where Lionel Messi grew up and first
kicked a ball His Image is everywhere
with murals celebrating their favorite
star
he was a funny child his life was soccer
more than anything playing with all the
kids here's what he is today for all of
us we think he's a great he's a star but
people like me still see him as the
child who continues to play who
continues to share and be a team player
and a nice guy
the truth is that he deserves the best
in life because he's a beautiful person
a born leader and he will make all of us
happy we are already champions
nearby in the town of sarandino a huge
hand woven number 10 Argentina shirt
hangs above the streets a tribute to
Messi and his teammates who play France
in the final of Qatar 2022 13 000
kilometers away
it gives me goosebumps because behind
the shirt there is work there is heart
there is blood
Sunday's match will be Messi's Second
World Cup final having lost to Germany
in 2014. this year's opponents present a
formidable challenge France are the
defending Champions and are aiming to
become the first team to retain the
title since Brazil in 1962.
it's going to be a close game I feel
that both teams will be careful I feel
that they are going to attack because
that is a style they both have I think
Argentina will go with a line of five
again with three down and two more open
going down and forming the line of five
I feel that they will defend and not
attack as much because we know what is
at stake the two teams will go one step
further up the ladder it's a pivotal
match and whichever way it goes it will
be the third cup for whoever wins
at Messi's former Club Newell's old boys
there's a confident mood ahead of the
big game
we're going to win that's how it is
because these guys are up for it because
of the way they treat each other apart
from doing it for Argentina they're
going to do it for Messi needs it and
will end up setting all the records
because that's how it is it's crazy
this mural in Rosario reads from another
galaxy and from my neighborhood Victory
on Sunday would see Messi repeat Diego
maradona's achievement of 36 years ago
and take his popularity to even greater
Heights
David Stokes Al Jazeera